i'm supposed to meet a man here  to take me to the compound  came from the west right  here is getting pretty bad out that way  now  folks turning on each other  so why the compound  seems a strange place to be heading  once in a lifetime opportunity  what is it  come here  look at this  that's gold  we just found a pile of gold  one of us left to get the excavator to  get it out  i think i'll stay with the gold  you gotta watch your water  gonna stay out of the sun  ain't no joke out here  how much longer going as fast as i can  so you're here on your own  you need to leave  out here  things start to get real strange  where are you  i think they're hiding something gotta  get rid of her  where are you i'm cold i did my party i  found it  it's mine  i can handle it  [Music]  you